oui merci monsieur le sénateur j'ai pas
regardé la photo de tf1 mais je crois
avoir tout à leur donner des indications
assez précise les trente à quarante
mille personnes dont j'ai parlé n'était
pas aux abords strict du stade j'ai
expliqué qu'elle était au delà des
barrages au delà au sud des barrages que
nous avions les barrages où le savez
étaient pas directement sur l'entrée du
stade mais contrôler l'accès à ce parvis
du stade voilà donc pour être très
précis bien évidemment il n'y avait pas
trente à quarante mille personnes devant
les portillons du stade pour essayer de
vous répondre c'est évident mais jamais
personne a desire je ne sais pas d'où
vient ce débat je vous dis moi les
indications que j'ai les observations
que j'ai fait et les comptes rendus que
j'ai donné au ministre il me semble
d'ailleurs que ce qu'avait expliqué le
ministre était en la matière assez clair
je ne crois pas que il était dit par
quelqu'un que c'était la principale
cause du report du match tel qu'exprimé
me semble-t-il par l'uefa et par la
fédération française la principale cause
de report du match enfin des aéroports
du match et elle fait que tous les
spectateurs n'étaient pas encore rentrés
dans le dans le match dans le stade
pardon et qu' il y avait d'ailleurs on
le constate et assez facilement en
regardant les gradins du stade les
supporters anglais n'étaient pas tous là
donc s'ils n'étaient pas tous là c'est
qu'ils étaient à l'extérieur où était-il
en partie devant le stade mais d'autres
étaient ailleurs mais je ne peux pas
répondre à votre question quand vous
dire où il était mais il n'était pas
dans le stade ça c'est une évidence et
je crois que personne ne peut constater
leur absence il sent arriver
progressivement et ce qui a expliqué
cette décision du monde sportif de
reporter le le le le début du match
c'était notre grande crainte c'est
qu'effectivement il en a ils arrivent
d'autres supporters qu'ils fassent
encore plus pression sur le dispositif
déjà en difficulté de contrôler au
strict aux abords du stade car le
problème était à ce moment-là de savoir
si suffisamment aurait des billets juste
[Musique]